ابعدت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المحاميه
والمدافع عن حقوق الانسان الفلسطينيه
المقدسي صلاح الحموري الى فرنسا التي يحمل
جنسيتها صباح اليوم والغت اقامته في القدس
وذكرت الاذاعه الرسميه العبريه ان التمثيل
عمليه الابعاد تم بعد توقيعه وزيره
الداخليه المنصرفه للشكيد على تنفيذ الامر
وكانت سلطات الاحتلال اعتقلت الحموري
اداريا في شهر مارس اذار الماضي بتهمه
العضويه والنشاط في خليه تابعه للجبهه
الشعبيه لتحديد فلسطين وفي تصريح السابق
قالت والدته الحموري ان نجلها يرفض
الترحيل ويطالب بالعيش في القدس مع اسرته
من القدس معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد المزيد حول ظروف ابعاد صلاح
الحموري
هو حقوقي فلسطيني تعرض للاعتقال سبع مرات
منذ عام 2001 اخرها كان في شهر اذار مارس
الماضي حيث وضع
رهن الاعتقال الاداري وصدر بحقه قرار
الابعاد والذي يصفه الفلسطينيين بانه قرار
متعسب هو انتقامي ووصفته الجبهه الشعبيه
بانه ياتي في ايطاليا واسمتها عمليه
التطهير العرقي الذي تمارسه قوات الاحتلال
ضد الفلسطينيين في القدس فجر هذا اليوم تم
نقله في طائره رحله متوجهه الى فرنسا في
عمليه ابعاد اتخذ قرار بشانها وزيره
الداخليه والسلطات الاسرائيليه بعد ان
رفضت المحكمه الاسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال
الالتماس الذي كان قد قدم بهذا الشان
الحموري تعرض للاعتقال وكان رهن الاعتقال
الاداري مرارا لكن ابرز فتره اعتقال له
كانت عام وخمسه عندما وضع وحكم عليه
بالسجن لسبع سنوات واقل هي سبيله في اطار
صفقه همم عرف بصفقه شريف او صفقه التبادل
التي كانت بين اسرائيل
وحركه حماس في عام 2011 لكنه بعدها تعرض
ايضا للاعتقال عده مرات وكان ضمن ملاحقه
متعمدا هو حقوقي متخصص بالدفاع عن حقوق
الاسرى الفلسطينيين لكن اللافت في الموضوع
ان مساله همم انه كان ممن اخلي سراحهم في
اطار صفقه وفاء الاحرار عام 2011 وبعدها
ظلت سلطات الاحتلال تلاحقه وتقوم باعتقاله
ابعاده الى فرنسا جاء بحكم ان والدته
فرنسيه وكذلك زوجته وكانوا قد اعتقلوا
زوجته لثلاثه ايام وهي حامل همم قبل ذلك
ورحلوها ايضا هي الى فرنسا بحكم انها تحمل
الجنسيه الفرنسيه همم
في الامر ايضا انه لم يكن هناك تدخل من
قبل السلطات الفرنسيه او الحكومه الفرنسيه
بحكم انهم مواطن يحمل الجوازه سفرها لكن
هذا التطور بنظر الفلسطينيين هو تطور غايه
في الخطوره اقدمت عليه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المنصرفه من خلال وزيره
داخليتها المتشدده ايلت- جاكيت التي وقعت
الامر الذي يتم تنفيذه صباح هذا اليوم بعد
ان كان الحموري قد قضى في السجن همم منذ
شهر اذار مارس الماضي وعمليه ترحيله يرى
فيها الفلسطينيون بانها عوده للسياسه
اعتقدوا ان سلطات الاحتلال ربما توقفت
عنها فقد طالت العديد من الفلسطينيين اكثر
من 1370 في فلسطينيه منذ الاحتلال ابعدوا
بهذه الطريقه او بغيرها بعضهم عاد وبعضهم
ما زال بعد في الخارج ولم يسمح له بالعوده
شكرا